Wow. Well, well go to your mom's house,
Christina. Visits. Increase Increase
Frank Sinatra. Yeah, I'm not entertained.
I don't think it's great.
It's also not thinking why you say that?
He's singing singing.
I can sing like him.
Hey
Bob.
Really man. It's like no, but what about
Cassie? Kindness thing is
that one. But most of it is a
come walking in those
ladies at the fuck man,
bring me a drink. I love slot. And
you're like, that's not really singing
man, man. Man,
man, man, man, man, man,
man,
man.
There's ladies at the great man. Yeah,
that's a, what is that? That's
[inaudible] Sinatra. Nice.
It's really good. Yeah.
By who is that? Hello?
Hello something I can't see. Um, yeah,
really good song. I like it.
It's not just terrible. Terrible.
Yeah. And it's a very, it's just,
it's too overexposed to like,
I feel like you hear Sinatra and I'm very
corporate environments to buy that Sig
flow. Sorry, sig flow. You know
like when you go to a bar stocks,
it's like a corporate approved type of
music. Yeah. I think cause it's just,
it's been around for so long.
I also feel like it's fake
nostalgia. Right, right. The
guy that tried, he's like,
I just, you know, I love
that throwback feel. Yeah.
Right.
But it's been so overused that it's not
even authentic anymore cause they'll
play Frank Sinatra, you know, at the
Mcdonald's or whatever and you're like,
well this isn't cool.
Yeah,
I know.
You know. You know what I'm saying? I'm
only talking about, yeah, talking about,
you usually hear Sinatra and like Yuppie
places like our crate and barrel or a
Serola Tabula or Williams and Sonoma.
Like when you're buying your
hundred dollar pots and pans.
Yeah. People like to force
that. Yeah. That feel, eh,
but it's good that bay to the bar.
I think maybe,
actually I just realized
that's my issue with it.
I feel like the person act like
they're into that whole thing.
Right?
Like when did you meet
somebody authentically playing
Sinatra at their house?
But that's what relax
too. You're like, oh,
it's all about the authenticity as
bullet points. Like a 70 year old guy.
Yeah. My Dad. Yeah. My Dad does
likes Frank Sinatra. It doesn't fit,
but it's a, it feels, it feels like
it's fake. I'm like love for it.
I think you're right. I
think you're, I think it's a
manufacturer. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
You're right. A fake nostalgia. And at
that point it's not neat. It's not cool.
It's not raw. Yeah, absolutely.
Right. Yeah. The fuck is she doing
Schnitzel looking for food?
She just went behind it.
She got up on the couch. She hasn't,
maybe she's lost a few pounds. She has,
cause I had been cutting her kibble but
she doing man she's looking for is for
things to get into.
I cut her kibble intake so she
still eats the table scraps to fall,
but it's actually,
it's only been like a week of doing
that and she's already dropped some lbs.
It looks like. Oh for my uh, audio
people, I get a lot of people that,
you know,
ask questions and make suggestions about,
so I have an update on this computer show
with tutors or he would open the show.
I was wondering if we should watch the
mic guy because this discussion you're
about to get into sounds about
as interesting. I don't know.
I don't have him cute up, but I'm
saying it sounds like a real boring.
Are you going to get real technical on it?
Well,
it's a little technical but I think
we have a lot of people that have have
written in about it. Okay. So, so we
do the show with two two computers,
right. This basically becomes
the, the video computer,
the one I'm sitting in front of
and it's like a backup audio thing,
but the majority of the audio stuff
plays from the second computer. Right.
So that one for the second
time got butt fucked,
stopped working.
I took it in.
They will have already replaced a
logic board on it and I go, what?
She just did a code on it.
She reset the p Ram and then the p ramp
that I prayed to bring it back here,
plug it in.
Not the same issue but not playing.
So now I think it's actually the
Jack that I plugged in there.
So I'm going to get into cables plugging
and unplugging the cable and plug cause
you're messing with it. I then
somebody else. Yeah. You kind of,
you kind of solved it. I think
that there's also a, um, uh,
there's a software that somebody
told me to download to, to do,
to streamline this more.
So I'm going to try that too.
But we still don't have it today
because today I couldn't hook it up.
It's still an issue with it. Kind of.
It just fucking, it's so annoying.
It is annoying.
It sucks cause we do our show off of
that and all our drops are on there so I
had to transfer some. It's
like, but, and then I have that,
that version of the show
opened. That doesn't sound
the same for whatever reason.
It doesn't sound the same on this
computer. I don't understand that at all.
It doesn't work. Sucks. Yeah. So weird.
So we're just going to have to power
through, glass it through glass through.
Um, all right. Should we open the show?
I properly [inaudible] on my leather
mask or, yeah, it was the real math.
Let's fucking do this shit, man.
A virgin out from his chest,
from the covering with the
tension of pulling on the tail.
Those muscles are actually being
squeezed out into pushing out the penis.
Okay,
well welcome
to your mom's house.
And Christina
came here.
I know
DOR did. And it's the, that's all funky
sounding. I don't, I have no idea. Um,
it's a real low fi version.
I don't get it, man.
Anyways.
Um,
but scoop Bedo the de la God,
that's the way it goes sometimes abroad.
Well Not Take Yo rob far bup, bup, bup.
So you hang with the fellows
and you have a drink.
Oh six loaded up, bup, bup, bup, bup.
I'm the most popular
singer of the 20th century.
Right. And it also hearkens back
to a time like, isn't that the 50s?
Isn't that a time of like total sexism,
racism when the white man
while still does dominate,
but like a time when Whitey really fucking
let you know that he was in charge.
I had a real special black with them.
You know they had one, right? Yeah,
they're allowed one. There
you are. Cool. And he's right.
He was black and he was Jew met
both quotas and then they're like,
the rest of us are white.
We're not racist. Fucking
Sam is here the whole time.
Right? Yeah. Yeah, totally. And I,
but ironically that time in Vegas
is where those guys are performing.
That's back when Vegas was
about, it was Sodom and Gomorrah.
Yeah. It was, you know,
hookers and drugs and really
changed. Oozing. Yeah.
It's good and so crazy. And
like Nevada now has, uh,
I think they're, I think they passed
recreational marijuana. Not like that.
You couldn't do find it before,
but imagine to add that into the mix.
Like right now, weed is legal. You can
walk on the streets with open beverages.
Uh,
the Raiders are probably gonna be
I being serious. Yeah. That's chaos. You
should not have the writers there course,
but it's also on Nepal. It's perfect. It
is no better town to have the Raiders.
That is where they should be. Yeah. Just
amazing. It's just going to be people
shooting guns in the air, like, yeah,
we totally nuts by the way.
Thanks everybody that came out.
Um, Huntington, Long Island,
Montclair, New Jersey, and Atlantic
city, another shitty isn't it?
Lacks Shitty, far Atlantic,
shitty, really fun shows. Uh,
my parents came to Atlantic shitty show.
I know,
cause your dad called this morning and
he never asks to speak to me directly,
but you handed me the phone
and I got really excited.
He was really demanding it and I got
super pumped because I was like, oh,
we're gonna do some brown talk. I mean
the dog and I, yeah. And what he does,
and he does this every time,
is he just talks about how proud he
is of you and how much he loves you.
He's like, you know,
or Zena Brown, a Tommy,
he's just such a great kid.
Great.
And he just talks about
how proud he is of you,
of how well you did at the show and
your performance and your routine.
And then notice lately,
nothing like start to cringe more
than I would. He goes, hey, you know,
I watched the crowd.
Okay, I watched them. And,
uh, you, uh, you, you know,
you talk about things that they
also can relate to now I'm like,
yeah,
it's called the top. That's what
we all do. I think. Yeah. There,
because if you don't, people don't laugh.
Right. You got to hit a common ground,
but you, you have, uh,
I don't know really just,
it's really neat. No, try it.
Can I tell you what he said to me? That
was the best two gene. He goes, uh, uh,
uh, uh, audience was really excited.
See him like really excited and
this girl next to me was just dying,
just dying everything Tony,
he was saying.
And then I did really laughing and I was
so tempted to tell her that to my son
and at the end of the show I leaned over
and I said, that's my son. Yeah. And uh,
she really flipped out.
Yeah.
I told him, he was telling
me that. He was like, yeah,
I said to a somebody that's my son,
and then the guy goes,
top dog. And I go, yeah.
He goes, I couldn't help myself, Tony.
And my mom was like, don't please.
When she told me, she was like, I said,
please don't please, please, please.
Now your mom, you said, um,
it has been having a better,
excuse me time at your shows
lately because you've been,
uh,
encouraging actually demanding
that she drink before the show.
Right. So that has been a
huge, huge help. I tell my dad,
give her too, because she really
can't handle her alcohol. Yes.
The best. Give her too. Um, and,
and make sure that, you know, she's good
and sauced it works so well. First of all,
she gets lightheaded and loose.
Yeah.
She didn't even remember what
the show about it the best when
she can't criticize or critique or not
what she has. I'm not worried about
that.
I just don't want her to like really
internalize anything really. Yeah.
I mean like she just, at this point she
feels like, so because she'll, if she,
if she's sober, she'd be like,
that thing was kind of, you know,
that wasn't very nice to say that. Yeah.
At this point my dad was like, you know,
that was true and that my mom goes,
what?
It's like that whole story he told about
me. What story? I didn't even Amnesia.
None of it. None of it. None. I love
it. Lou went over. So I was like,
this is the only way she's
allowed to come to them.
Yeah. Well we instituted this policy
when she came to visit last time. Yeah.
Uh,
she came in and we immediately gave her
a drink and it ended up being the best
time we ever had with your folks. Cause
every time she'd come over I'd be like,
Charlie, you want, you want your peanut
Greens? You want your peanut agrees? No,
no I cannot. And then I would just
pour a, for her memory you would like,
tell me like, just pour for
end. Pour her a big one. Yeah.
I shall never take a second for, yeah.
So I was giving her like, you know,
tall boys of Pinot grigio
and it was fantastic for us.
Like I remember they were down
on the floor with Ellis laughing.
It was great fighting for his affection.
It was the best time. Alcohol is the,
Oh, this is, this is the other
thing I wanted to tell you.
The last time she went to the,
the, uh, the live show. Yeah.
She drank and she goes, you know
what I have to tell you, did I,
I love the show.
Is that no more.
You don't do the f anymore and
you don't say you're masturbating.
And my dad looked at me like,
like, what are you talking about?
He talked about that for like 15,
right? What show are you at it?
But then we realized it was the,
the sauce, the, the, yeah, the
sauce. The sauce, you know,
alcohol and drugs are great
for some people's personality.
Like my father is off the booze now.
Yeah. And he's a miserable content.
Right. And I don't like him
over because he's not fun.
And my dad's so much better
than when he's drinking. Yeah.
So people are like that. I have friends
too that are, I mean, obviously, you know,
everyone knows this.
Some people,
it's fucking toxic to the point
where you see that second drink,
go down someone's hat and you're like,
oh yeah, I had friends like that.
Even at high school. Yeah. And I recognize
like once this dude has three beers,
he headbutts people.
Right. Um, and then when,
then there's people who just are funneled
like Burt's a great example. Okay.
Exemplary drinker. Yeah.
Bert Burnt Chrysler. Yeah.
The unfortunate problem is that he's
great when he's drunk. Yeah. Yeah.
And I had been drunk just drinking.
You don't even know that he's drunk now.
You don't know. Like, he's so fun. He's a
fun, fun guy. And my dad, the same thing,
like a party drunk. Like he's
actually kind of a fun dude. Yeah.
I'm sure he's had a few in him.
He used to crank up the ABA. Yeah.
In the house and dance and like Andrix
Oh Henrik, I was on the darker days.
That's when he was running lights off.
Yeah.
I'd come home from like high
school if, I don't know, like 15.
I come home at night from like
hanging out with my friends and uh,
he'd be sitting in the listening to
Hendrix listening to it so loud that I,
I was like, oh my God, did somebody
break in and turn off our stereo?
Like I would walk in and it'd be like
blaring and he would also have the
television on muted,
which makes me crazy personally.
Like if something's on an,
I can't understand what's
happening, I can't do it.
And he would just mute the TV and then
listen to Hendrix and just sit in the
fucking dark, like, get weird. I was
like, cool. This is normal. Right.
Functional value. That's just how I used
to get down. Yeah. That was his unwinding,
right? Yeah. That was a
weekend. That wasn't a weekday.
That was like a Friday night kind of
wind down. That's the end of the night.
Definitely.
That was like midnight.
I'm rolling in and I remember
he was into that Marley mix to,
you know, I'm sorry. Yeah. There was some,
a song that he played. Yeah.
That was like, oh, this is a,
you know, he likes that stuff. Yeah.
You know what really made me laugh that
he used to do with my ex step mom is a,
she fucking hated German Christmas music
and my dad would play this one CD that
we had and there was one song,
Hi Jay,
boom by g and she would fucking,
she would never get mad,
but when hide you boom. Baiji came on
just to irritate it. Oh, of course.
That was the whole fun is that my dad
would look at me because he had had a few
in him and he was like, you ready for
the Christmas music? And I was like, yes,
because I knew that she was going to
get fucking hate it so much. She just,
she would say that.
Yeah.
Hi.
Did you move by g? I hate
these songs still good. Again,
like folks she hated for like you
with red, red wine. I hate red,
red wine. But you don't play it to
agitate me like on Christmas. No,
but I mean it's not a bad idea.
I'm not going to not start doing that.
That's terrible with the boy.
That's terrible. Put whatever.
I'll get mad. Yeah, that's
the fun part is pissing Mama.
What's your read song? I'm trying to
think. You're a, it makes you see, fuck,
I definitely have some. It's just I can't
really access and what it is right now.
You know you don't, but you don't
get as angry on arbitrary shit.
Like I do know you get
angry at people like pro,
like in competence makes you angry.
I get mad at like irrational,
like songs make me angry. Yeah. I'd say
I'm healthy. What that's about. Yeah,
I'd say I'd say the diagnosis probably.
Yeah.
Well definitely one of us had a
dad that drank and the dark. Yeah,
I'd say so. Psychologists definitely.
You're definitely the mental
health champ of the both of us.
I work a lot harder to see.
I heard that one before.
Yeah.
Yeah. My Dad. Yeah. Ah, oh, he's,
they're so sweet.
They're going
to come back and visit soon.
I can't wait till I had my dad and my
mom and I'm married. My mom asked him,
will you ever date your mom married her?
That's so true.
That's so true. Yeah. You. Oh, you married
her this weekend and I did Atlantic city.
I did him and my mom the other day.
What was the ceremony like? Oh,
it was real nice. And Atlantic
City, you know, we had it.
We did it right there at the Borgata.
Oh, that's cool. Very cool. Yeah,
it was fun. It was actually really fun.
You had a good time hanging with her? Uh,
hung out. Uh, she's, she's the slot
champs. Uh, she's in the slots,
loose loose slots,
but um,
she's not really good at it so that's
kind of real funny. That's hilarious.
Then the best thing is she has,
she's somebody who really sucks at it,
cause a perennial loser but
has all the advice for you.
So I always like the whole
time I'm with her, she's like,
this machine doesn't pay these
machine base. So you go like,
okay, you said to her machine
and then you're bedding too much.
I'm like [inaudible] like everything she
says, I just, I keep telling her, I go,
whatever your instincts tell you, do
the opposite. You're the fucking cooler.
Like you just kill a room. Well, I mean,
is there such a thing as a strategy for
slots? Well, I don't know if they're,
I mean probably not,
but there is there.
I do know this just from
somebody I know who has,
I'm sure he's lost a lot of money,
but I know there's a lot that want
a lot of money as well. I mean,
I believe you go,
you get into your range and you Max bet.
There's no point in men the bets
on those things because all the,
if you do hit something then
what's the point is if you bet,
but more so get like, get on a fucking
penny machine Max. So she's like,
don't bet so much. Which was
the Max bet on a penny? Well,
I mean some of them it might be like a
dollar a spin. And if you go to like the,
you know,
or you can do $3 or five or you can go
to the high limit slots and that $50 a
spin. But I just don't see the
point. I'm like, you never win.
And you're betting strategy never works.
So try the one. I'm telling you. No,
no. Yeah. Shin listened to you. Of course
not. But I still had fun watching her.
And then if it would, if she would
have hit something and we'd go like,
do you need nicotine meaning and it
would, uh, it would go like, you know,
pay out like $1 50 cents there. Look
at you. You're fucking killing it.
And do you get paid in pennies?
Does it come out in pennies? No,
just it just adds up and
you know, it doesn't pay. It
doesn't, pennies don't drop.
It just adds to your
bank. So it'd be like, oh,
it would hit and it'd be like
70 cents. Look at you. Oh Wow.
I can see their logic. I mean, if
you're not in it for the money,
just the excitement of the win.
Yeah, that is it. She gets a rush,
but she's always complaining
that she never gets like,
it never wins any real money and like,
cause you're not betting real money. Yeah.
You can get a pony up. Yeah. She won't
do it. She's like, no, it's too much.
Maybe it's good that she's not into
aggressive gambling. She fucking,
she's so bad.
So bad.
But your mom's good at bridge.
Yeah.
Well there's no real like you
are lucking out on a machine.
There's no strategies pressing a button.
Yeah.
But I just think that like whenever
she thinks it's time, I go,
whenever your body tells you,
get up from this machine move
and whenever your body says go to that
machine, walk away. In other words,
you stop trusting yourself.
You're bad at this.
It's like when my mother used to give
me advice. Yeah. I'd be like, oh, okay,
I'll just do the opposite of what you
said because I know you're fucking crazy.
Do the opposite of what you
think is literally would.
And then my life was super happy. She
told me not to marry you. She was like,
you should get back together with your
lawyer ex boyfriend. I was like, oh,
that means I got to marry Tom.
Tom Is definitely in the winter
and see worked out. Yeah. She
didn't like you at all. She didn't,
didn't know you though.
She's crazy. Shared voices
telling her that you were, um,
you didn't like her really swear
to God. Yeah, she heard voices.
But sometimes you got to
trust those voices. She did.
Sometimes you do.
Where's the,
I'm trying to find the whale decks.
No wheel. Dick's is right here.
I was trying to find something else. Um,
but okay, we can get in a wheelchair.
I love this clip. I was
just so taken with this. Oh,
I remember now. Okay. What
is it Jane? No, I remember,
I remember what I was looking
for. Um, this lady here,
this is massive whale.
Yeah. Is beached. Yeah.
It's so enormous. It's
so cool. So huge. Um,
and she is a, an expert. And then there's
like, there's a, there's a, what is that?
A forklift?
I mean a
fucking thing is so massive
that, you know, there's a,
there's a team of people on the
beach and she's the scientist.
Obviously she's the one that, that knows
about the specimen. And then, you know,
covering the tension
of pulling on the tail.
Those muscles are actually being
squeezed out into pushing out the penis.
It's so big
city. Can you hold for a
second so I can show the penis?
Oh till I tell you,
cause we just looking at something,
he doesn't say what Stop Day is massive.
It's bananas
Sheath pulling the Penis.
Alright,
I didn't cut it off guys.
Come on.
Do you know what I love about her is
that everybody's like, I'm a nerd.
I'm an I play video games. I'm a nerd.
Like no, no, no. That's a real nerd. Yeah.
She's a real nerd. It's awesome.
Great. Yeah, but that's a fucking nerd.
Not Farell or whoever. Cruel
wrapper. Right, right, right.
The black guy with glasses
isn't a fucking nerd.
That's a nerd and a sweater.
Well, I'm such a nerd.
I know. I am a girl who plays video games
like, oh, okay. I've read two books.
I'm a nerd, right? No, this lady knows
everything about whales. Everything.
Her life is Wilcox. Yeah. I
don't know about just the Cox.
She just loves licking them.
Holding them. Suck on them. No.
Putting the warn her phrase, the semen
on her friend. Hard drive round Pam.
She loves me. This is a whale's penis.
No, my life. This is only part of it.
Notice by the way, there's no bone in
his penis. It's completely flexible.
Whoa,
whoa.
Give you an idea of the size of this cock.
It's sitting on her lap.
She's bent down.
Yeah.
And like she's holding basically,
I don't know, not even,
not even half of it with one hand
and then flapping open handed the,
the, uh, the end of it,
flapping it around. It looks
like a, it's like a fire hose,
but I mean, like they've already in
gorge. It's actually bigger than that.
You know, it actually looks like
a safety cone painted black. Um,
or like a black person's leg.
Yeah.
There's like a leg.
No. Yeah. No.
I think the safety cone was a better,
like, imagine a six follow a safety count,
but a black one, right? Yeah.
Yeah. Not a bad person is like,
okay.
It's actually probably the most
amazing penis in the animal world.
I love her so much. Yeah.
Now here's why. Probably,
and she makes a really good point of
why it's the most amazing penis. Yeah.
It's because they can't stop
the mount. Oh, right. Yeah.
Take us this penis is prehensile how when
you're a whale you can't grab another
well with your flippers and hug it and
make love to it and you don't really have
very good hits so you can't
really do that motion.
So you got to reach the female anyway
you can. And this is what they use.
A penis is completely flexible.
Their kid penetrate from
almost any position.
Wow. So crazy. It is an amazing, she's
right. They can't hug. They can't thrust.
Like how did dolphins fuck, we should
try it. We should try this approach.
What's that approach?
Bed.
Just like no mounting,
no thrusting.
And when do we do, I don't know.
We just have to, it's just science.
So what else? Don't have a
favorite position. You know,
like there's no such thing
as missionary position.
All the whales and one of the few
animals that do make belly to belly like
primates,
it's because of this ultra humongous
penis that they could actually even have
babies.
I love
her so much, man. The thing is don't
you love checks like this? Yeah,
she's cool man.
He's like so into it.
She's like the only person that knows
this much about this whale's penis. Yeah.
Super stoked about it out here.
So that's really the land joy.
I know you love the
penis or we have to stop.
We haven't got to get this whale off the
beach. Or you finished it and know then.
Yes. Okay. All right. This
theme dot. You've got so hot and
unbelievable.
Yeah, that's cute. Right?
That's their little comedy.
He had to go in and you know it's coming.
Yeah.
Okay.
That is massive.
It is massive.
What else? Basle this basil. I like the
a worker's laughing. That's my favorite.
They're like no change from fifth
grade on. We don't change course.
You shouldn't go that big Ole Dick.
Yeah, it's true. Yeah. It's
something you laughing now.
A Dick,
of course.
Especially because she's super
stoked about seeing a whale deck.
If my dad was on that beach right,
then hundred percent wouldn't be. Yeah.
I still love it.
Seven or eight years old,
pollute free lap dance. Love those
jokes. Oh, I got a little projects
crazy. Um, oh, you mentioned.
So I figured I would.
Uh,
you know,
I have come all over.
My face might have come all of ours,
all over Maine.
We played, uh, this lady last week.
Same Guy will never even touch
his own calm or tastes all come.
I've seen this happen so many times with
guys. You know what I'm talking about?
Yeah.
You posted,
you posted I are on your,
no,
it was the Instagram teaser
that I'm saying the weekly
teaser. Here's the thing.
I think we should go
on strike against calm.
Accum strike somebody a note.
I noticed that you noticed it,
right? Somebody who was like, Hey, is
that and actually tagged this woman?
Do you know her name? Oh, well
I can find it. Hold on. So God,
it's always weird when you play a video
like this and then you talk a lot of
shit. Yeah. And you're a total asshole.
And I mean, and then it's like, oh,
it's a real person. Yeah. I hate
that. I fucking hate that. Uh,
I've always feel horrible and
I'm like, God, I know he's,
we shouldn't have been such, but I didn't
realize something. Uh, what is her name?
Oh, here she is. Uh, she's on Instagram.
Shahrzad Shahrzad should we give her
lab? I don't want to. Yeah, it's okay.
Okay. Uh, Shahrzad and Morgan. Yeah.
And she's written a book, which is
why we wanted to kind of, right.
Yeah. I mean, look, she's um, here
Shahrzad what kind of name is that?
No. Shahrzad Morgan. Um, but it says,
oh, she said in that comment
that she's an escort,
which explains everything. Yeah.
Because we were like, wait,
why is this woman had this problem in
life that these guys are just coming all
over her and asking her to taste
it and well, that makes sense.
If she's an escort then
she's a professional come
dealer. You know what I mean?
I see it in there. It
doesn't say I have no, I,
here's what I have that she
wrote a book called pleasure,
a memoir and you can get
it@mypleasurebook.com. So
just to give her a shout out,
cause since we shit on her so
hard last week. Yeah. Uh, sorry.
Shahrzad we didn't know you were an
escort. If I knew that then it would,
it changed the game and she has a new
book coming out called what I did for sex
and what it can do for you. Oh,
that's cool. So now we totally,
we thought she was like a new
divorce, say maybe and yeah, she was,
which might be true also as yeah.
Who knows?
But that totally changes the
whole nature of the beast here.
Yeah. Um, and she did, she,
she was nice enough that after we
fucking absolutely shit all over this,
um, where's, she said, well thanks
for the compliment on my teeth. Yeah.
She does have a really nice to you.
I know.
And we compliment and shoot and of all
the things she said, she pointed that out.
Nice Lady. Yeah, she's
nice. She says here,
mother has a bachelor of
science in Computer Science,
Mba and she does a TM high now.
Just like me,
just like Asian genes, just like Asian
genes. Agent jeans. Oh our, yeah.
Our agent does TM. Yeah. I'm
the only one that's not on you.
You're not onboard board
the, the cold train. No,
but I'm going to do it because you guys
got me both thinking about it so much,
girl. You got me thinking about it.
Thinking about how much I love you.
I love you.
Yeah, it's good. You should try it.
Um, just check it out if you like it.
If we're not, then you don't
have to wipe. Come on your face.
I meditating right now
in your mouth to come.
Remember I didn't the white tiger say
that did she would like to draw in the
essence? Yeah. She would put the cum
on her face and meditate and how veal.
I want to talk about the white
tigress practice holding the penis.
And she was hosed
by, uh, some fucking guy
like the, the guy 20. Yeah.
This activation God is activation.
Some guy like that was like,
you don't want to be a white
tigers. And she was like, okay.
Okay. If she get a special
title, like White Tiger. Yeah,
you get a white tiger is tight. Oh,
do I get an award? It's diploma.
So here's the thing, I think we
should go on strike against calm.
Okay. Well, if she's an escort then yeah.
Yeah. Okay. Another thing,
you should always wrap that
thing up. Yeah, yeah. Yes.
Right. Yeah. Gosh, that's a whole
other, that's a whole other thing, man.
Yeah, it's a lot. Yeah,
totally. Totally. Now, when
you use escorts, do you use
a condom? Uh, always. Always.
You can't play that game,
otherwise get burned by gonorrhea.
Used to say that all the time. Don't
we first started dating and I was like,
do you have any diseases I should
know about? And you're like, well,
I got burned by Garrett gonorrhea
one time. Twice. You got burnt twice.
Yeah, I did. I got burned
by gonorrhea twice.
That's true. But that's bacterial, so
that's fine. You can treat that. Yeah.
But you still don't want
it. What's it feel like? Um,
I dunno. It just, it doesn't feel
good. It feels better than it used.
Good. Yeah. Does It hurt when you pee?
Is that gonorrhea? Um, yeah. Yeah. It
Hurts when you pee. It doesn't look good.
It look like, um, it looks like you
got an infection on your deferral.
Yeah. What sluts gave you that? Oh,
just fucking dirty road
beef, man. Geez, Tom. Yeah.
I had a dream last night that you,
uh,
had sex was one of my close friends,
one of your real close friends that,
because then I wake up and
I'm mad at you all day.
Even though rationally I know
I shouldn't be unconsciously.
Every time I look at you, I feel just
a like a shiver of hate. And then I go,
oh wait. He didn't really do
anything. But I do hate you a little,
just a little bit today,
by the way. It's real cool.
And it's happened throughout
the course of our relationship.
We're, I would say today's
definitely one of the better days.
There's days where you carried anger
throughout the day from your dreams.
There couldn't be a more irrational
reason to be upset and you've been like,
it's fucked up. Oh, you've,
you've cited your dream as the reason
you're in a bad mood before. Well,
it's logical.
I mean,
dreams put you in a bad mood and then
I just have to remind myself constantly
that you didn't do the thing
you did. Yeah, yeah. Well,
yeah, I'll be liked it.
I did sex in your mind,
whatever. No one is hooking up with any
of your friends. You always say that.
Why would you say that it's true. No
one's so going to let any of your friends.
That's true. Why are you
saying that? Because you're
fucking your friends or dog.
The bounty hunter and they're not dogs.
They're not.
You got to fucking say that all the time.
It's like a rescue clinic.
That's so silly breed. Are you into
Christina's got him as a friend for sure.
You're so crazy.
If I just,
because I don't hang out with
superficial Kardashians girl.
Everybody wants,
I don't hang out with girls that spend
all their money on a liposuction.
And how about just a good friend that
looks kind of like you would that?
That's a problem on my friends.
Any Blondie's? Yeah, sure.
I don't know. I'm not, you know
what I like? That's so funny.
I like grumpy brunettes. Throw all
my friends and you know what I like,
so stop fucking around. Oh, that's
right. You're like Blondie's.
Maybe there's a reason I'm not friends
with any blinds because you'll start
sexting. Yeah, maybe. Or those
of your p s speaking of texts,
I got a very interesting one.
Holy Shit. It's not Salamay.
So to recap, don't want to change
her phone number at this point.
What year and a half ago.
And you started at first
getting job offers for a nurse.
She's got a lot of nursing
opportunities in Florida. Boca Raton,
I get the calls weekly,
we're hiring and Clearwater,
and then she never gets to the calls.
Then out of nowhere it was like,
where are you Aiden?
Where are you?
Where are you people or let people
love you still feel like that.
And then it was like you weren't at
your AAA today. And then we're like, oh.
And then there was the calls when eight
is checked himself out of the Rehab
Clinic and I got calls from his
shrinks and it was like eight us.
You can't just check yourself
out of treatment. I really
need to speak with you.
This is doctor Blah Blah Blah.
So,
and it was Solomon and then Salami,
which is slowed down. It's been,
it's been months since we've done a
Persian voicemail and I'm just oh,
sad spot on my nose or something.
Lady knows that called saw them as well.
We don't know cause we just, when you
lose hope with Salomon and she's like,
I don't know
that's somebody by the way,
I think I put it together
cause it's an older lady. Yeah.
If somebody that has all her friends'
phone numbers written down, interesting.
Every phone number in her life is written
down as a digit off and that's why
interesting theory. I like that. I
think it's just, she doesn't call,
she opens her little booklet,
her old school handwritten shit possibly
supposed to be at three and it's an
eight or something.
You know,
you remember that time she told Salami
to put plastic bags in the trees for the
squirrels that it wards off score.
Somebody found photo of that.
That's something that people do.
You know crazy people do of course
is a squirrel problem that severe and
pervasive in California looking
squirrels trying to get some food.
What do they do? What? What
damage do squirrels do? I
mean at least in city life,
like, okay, they're kind of
annoying, but I do have this,
can I tell you what happened? Yeah,
yeah, of course. So for Atus I get,
I get a phone call yesterday
from an area code. I'm not,
I know I don't have friends in like,
this is not for me.
And I just let it go to voicemail because
I'm with little jeans and we're riding
a train. It's cute. And then I get a
text from the number, it says hello.
And I was like, do I like who is
this? And I write back, who is this?
And this person just sends a photograph
of a $20 bill with just bricks of pills
and writes back Rick with the xannies
like,
oh, he's looking for, he's not
looking for Salamay or Schnoz.
Atus yeah. So I was tempted to write back
like, Bro, this is an eight is his phone.
But then I started, my maternal
instinct has kicked in where I'm like,
I don't want this dealer to know
that eight is, has changes number,
because then he's just going
to fucking try to find him.
So I'm just going to not, I'm doing
radio silence on the drug dealer. Yeah.
Let him figure this out on his own.
I'm not going to help aid as get pills.
Of course. That's a ton of
Xanax though, if you guys are.
Wow. I didn't know. That's
how, I mean, I'm such a square,
like I'm not even sure what
Xanax looks like. Really.
I'm like this guy's, you know, for
a hundred of them in the metal,
that is so amazed. I got to really
cherish that one. Really Great.
So that was pretty exciting news.
We watched a good movie last
night for once and I fell asleep.
It was that good action
movie. English people. Yeah,
I really liked that one. Yeah.
And there were a lot of chapters in
it. The lead is a Chav, a Roadman,
a lot of road when we're in it,
rode men's
blood, fat, blood, blah, that there was a
couple blood and films in there. Really?
I couldn't even understand what the
henchman would be like. Blood, what?
I was drinking wine last night, so I
don't, I, I can't understand things.
Oh yeah. Watch the rest of that
soon. We rented it. You know,
right now we should have bought it.
It's a good one.
Told you we buy all the shitty movies.
Then we rent the good ones.
We own Jack reacher to
reach all the way back.
It wasn't available for Shitty
rent. Fuck. That movie's terrible.
Fuck that movie. I saw him that finished
it. I think I'm going to finish it.
I'm going to finish it. Jessica angry.
Watch the rest of that pile of shit.
I want to wish I watching.
That movie really makes me wish I
knew Tom Cruise just so I could be uh,
um, call him and be like, how disappointed
are you in the way this turned out?
You would not do that if he was my friend.
You would not do that to a friend.
You don't do that to people do you know?
But he's so I feel like he's the type that
would be like, he would be like, yeah,
the fucking director of fuck this one up.
Oh,
I feel like he would leave with that.
I think he's the kind of guy
that he's really,
cause he's in a,
he's in Scientology and
he's super positive.
Like he's one of those people that
say something negative. It's true.
Well I think it was really positive
experience because like he's one of those
roads, a lot of people that worked on
it and I'm so thankful to all of them.
One of those fucking horse shit.
Whenever people would credit the crew,
that's when I'm like,
uh,
main thing is I'm just happy to have
this crew back and I'm just happy that I
was happy that these guys get to work.
Do they start doing that?
I'm sure that's what your main concerns.
My eyes can't real far back enough into
my head when I hear that that's what
Garth was doing last week.
Oh,
you know what's really great is that
everybody gets to see the grips and the
light guy like, no, you don't. One gives
a shit and neither do you know. Yeah,
you're the star. They always say ego.
When shows get renewed. They're like,
the main thing is that, that uh, this
crew gets to work another season.
That's what that was the main,
I'm sure I was so worried about
like what are they going to do,
like I'm taking care of, but like
these guys, that was my main concern.
Right. Yeah. I'm sure you're going
to make your wardrobe Mother Teresa.
I did find this from when I did get
gonorrhea, the first thing I kind of Rhea.
Yup.
Right.
Yeah. That was me taking a piss with
gunner. You never had an STD at all?
Not once. I mean, who knows.
We'll see what happens this
year in college or anything
like that. Never. Never,
never,
never.
I never have because I never
had sex with strangers.
People that I had a relationships with,
relationships with them. I had one eye.
What happened was I got bad bite
and I got sick. He got diarrhea.
He always knew your partner? Yeah. Yeah.
I was friends with the people I fucked.
I never fucks rangers generally as a rule.
It's still my,
um, my, I guess my numbers
are pretty split on that,
so I'm sweating jurors like some
half strangers, half. I know you can.
Yeah. So gross. Oh yeah.
I know one of your special strangers you
do you reminisce about her like once a
year? No, I don't. Oh yeah.
Reminisce about a stranger. I won't,
I won't say it on the air, but I'll,
I'll say this. It wasn't
a foreign country. Oh,
oh. See, look at your face
like I've talked about it.
I talked about it in my ass.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah. That's what I'm fucking talking
about. You're still reminiscing.
It's not positive.
Yeah,
but you're still like ruminating
about this wonderful woman.
You man making a greater point.
When I talk about her,
I'm making a bigger point to do it.
No, I'm going to have to watch the,
your new hour now to see what's going on.
I haven't watched you do
standup in a while cause he'd
been out of the, you know,
we've been different cities, but yeah.
Wow. Look at that. See I was right.
She's always on your mind.
This girl not always so special to
you and your hearts for real though,
Girl. Damn girl. Yeah,
you're in my heart. What,
what about her? It's not her. You
bring out like what makes you,
it's not her reminiscent.
Finally. It's not that it's a Ma.
I'm making a point about women. Yeah. Um,
giving guys the go ahead
and how,
how women have to basically
be more vigilant than men.
Because if you're a guy,
there's just a point where you don't
rationally think where the peg you got
gonorrhea from. I never
got gone to Rehab. Just,
no,
that's just,
just the point that I made though at the
point that I make is just about that.
It's not about it.
And you're absolutely right because
I remember as a young woman,
that dude's just,
all they want to do is come in you.
And she wasn't the only one who was like,
yeah, don't worry about it. Hell no,
no, no, no, no. She wasn't the
only one. Right. So dangerous.
Other floozies that I was with that
were like, don't worry about it. Yeah.
Yeah. We used to call your
sisters Luddy and scanty. Yeah.
There's still saved in my phone like that.
They got so mad. Maria was just like,
whatever. Jane was like,
that's disgusting. She,
she thought this whole time
he brought this up last week,
she thought this whole time I had
her saved in my phone as cunt.
She goes, she was just like so fucking
rude. They used to call me conti and I go,
oh my God, you can teach me know. Yes,
you'd like. She was so adamant. I go,
the nickname was [inaudible] like
a skunk. Yeah. And she was like,
Oh really? I go, yeah, you thought
it was con? She goes, yes. No,
it was scanty and Ludie.
Well, that makes sense now.
And when she was so upset about that,
she was like, this is so fucking rude.
Gosh,
I know you're a scant,
but now this scares me for our son
because all these hoes will be like,
you can just blow loads in me and then,
oh,
I'm preggers now your life is over and
you're at an 18 year old boy or 16 year
old boy. Well, okay. How do you
convince a young man to wear a rubber?
It's tough. I don't know, man.
We've got to use scare tactics.
I think that's what I was just thinking.
Now,
what can we say to him
that'll scare him enough?
Erash it's gotta be like right now I'll
take them down to skid row and you're
like, all these people didn't
work out. And he's like, what?
He started doing it like six years old.
It was really impressionable.
And every year you're like, I'm
going to go to no condom row. Oh,
that end drugs. You want
it, you would take pot.
This is what it looks like when you take
pie and be homeless or pregnant with
you.
Pregnant people are like,
they took about it took pot and they
smoked drugs and then the baby's growing
inside of you when you do that.
Yeah. That was the guys to
scare him. We'll say it makes your teeth
fall out to those tee ball and be like,
yeah, if you don't wear a condom,
teeth fall out to fall out. Yup.
Did you drugs? She's full out. It does.
Right enough. We got to get on that soon,
showing him pictures and I
will still be that thing.
So we feel really don't tell him that.
Stoops. Yeah. What's wrong? What?
You good man. Don't please. Um,
by the way,
I think of anything.
This is one of my favorite
things that come in and a while.
You remember obviously, right? Of course
you can't. I remember I was duct tape.
Yup. Guy Died. I'm so fired up.
So fire.
We have Korean food after this.
You're always in the Korean food cause
I have to shit, check this out. Yeah.
This is crazy,
man.
I mean he probably had ever,
ever opportunity to put
a brown paper poke over.
Isn't hey ed can poke holes in
it or a plastic bag, you know,
but duct tape.
I mean
it's,
it's just unbelievable.
People don't think this really happened.
This guy.
Oh God robbed the place with his face.
It's wrapped in duct tape and duct tape.
Hmm.
Isn't that insane to you?
Something tells me drug us.
We're responsible for that decision.
Yeah, a little bit. Of course.
Duct tape, man. Chuck
tape. It's bad. Yeah.
Bad. And it gets even more unbelievable
during a jailhouse interview.
The suspect said police
have the wrong guy.
Yeah.
Here he is.
They call you the tape bandage.
That's not, you look at me.
Don't look like a duck tape
Ben and baby. I'm not. No.
Duct tape banding loud one on one acid.
It's sucky.
You know this is not me. Now Look
Dude Mad. Do the homework, man.
He's got to go ask the
day pass duct tape tape.
I mean this is an insane
police. Say the suspect. It's
totally him. What? Lucky.
Apparently the bandit was sweating so
much. The duct tape didn't quite stick,
but of course he's not all that lucky.
Police say they have enough evidence
to make the charges stick butter. Yeah.
Yeah,
that's definitely duct tape.
I like his approach to the f to denying
it though. Hey man, it's not me.
Look at me man. Look at me.
You know me man. You know
me loud one on one sucky.
You know this is not me,
but God Dang.
Yeah, it is a good defense.
Take bandaid unreal man. Shit.
Go ask the day,
judge.
Do you know what I'm saying? Right, right
there. Shit. Amy, I'll tell you right now,
one on one man is that he
said one on one on one.
One on one. I didn't know
that. You said live one on one,
like maybe his radio station.
Okay.
One on one as if it's sucky.
You know, this is not me.
Oh fuck that guy saying,
oh he's a master vaccine,
but all I know is that this is another
guy that it's in a duct tape Dev.
That is an insane,
you imagine all these could cover your
face with how much that would hurt to
take that off. That
would hurt so bad. Yeah.
I mean I don't think just your face.
What about when you're,
when it's coming off the back
of your head. Oh Fuck Shit.
I was even worried putting
on that fetish mask.
You wear it when you weren't the live
show. Cause I thought bring down the back.
Oh, well and also it's, you know,
it's sticky. Yeah, you could.
I thought people put Vaseline on their
hair. B or something. I don't know.
But duct tape. Duct tape. There's
no way you pull it out. It
hurts for her so bad. Yeah.
That's even a bandaid hurts.
Could you imagine that tape?
What's Your Pronoun? Oh, does it?
Oh, it just, may I plug my
shell this week? Please do.
So I actually spoke to a nonbinary person
on this week's episode of that deep
bro. It drops a Monday night at
Minnesota. By the time this is up,
it will be there and it's on, I have a
youtube video, it's on my youtube channel.
Um, so listen to that seat
bro. And I, it was pretty,
pretty informative and it makes a lot
more sense now and actually hear it.
Yeah, they are. They, they did it.
I asked for the Pronoun and they did say
they'd prefer to be for Jews today. So,
uh, they were very kind
and generous and very cool.
Good sense of humor about it too.
Yeah, that's sounds super cool.
Check it out this week, just like,
hey. Hi. How are you? What's your name?
What's Your Pronoun? So we'll check that
out. That's deep, Bro. Um, all right.
Second announcement
on the live date front this week,
my shows are sold out
in Edmonton,
Calgary and the van contar
British come Mumbia in Canadia.
Um,
here's my big add ons.
I'll just tell you about a fourth show.
Fourth and final show has been
added at the Vic in Chicago.
March 19th. That is it. There's no more.
Thank you Chicago for all your support.
Uh, if you haven't gotten tickets,
now is your chance.
There is three weeks until the show.
So we need to a scoop
those up while you can.
A second show has been added
April six and Pittsburgh,
Pennsylvania. That is a
Thursday. We added a late show.
A third show has been added for Portland,
Oregon.
May 13th I had to move it to the next
month because the original next day would
have been Easter.
So I'm now coming back
May 13th see rattle meet,
rattle.
Washington also has a second
show on that Friday. Um,
so that's an added show in Seattle.
Um,
and there's going to be,
let's see,
there was one show added in DC because
those previous ones sold out and there
was, there's one coming up
that's going to be added that I,
it's not confirmed yet so I can't mention
it, but those are all the added shows.
I also promoted a green bay today, so I
know Green Bay is coming up. Bethlehem,
Pennsylvania is coming up. Check
those out. Tom Cigarette dotcom slash
poor go to Tom square.com James Jean,
I'd like to also announce that that's
deep Rowe has a t shirt that you can now
buy on [inaudible] dot
com slash put as at store.
It's up there if you want that.
Thank you everybody who came
out to see me this last weekend,
especially in during a torrential downpour
in La on the 17th that was bananas
and it was so fun and a lot of mommies
and on at flappers. Thank you guys.
So April 13th through 15th Bray
Improv and Bray California.
April 28th through 29th
Sacramento at the punchline.
May 4th through fifth fart.
Nick's Arizona at stand up live and then
May 19th through 20th June Dork titties
at Gotham comedy club.
June one through three Denver comedy works
at the downtown one June 16th through
17th man,
Fran disco at the punchline,
tickets@thousandranch.com.
Bunch of shit coming up. Well,
I got something coming up, you know,
and I mean, I'm can announces coming up.
You got to finally fucking
common up guys after years.
That's great genes. I announced it
officially. Yeah, but that's really great.
I know. So excited. It's about time. Yeah.
There was so many mommies that came out.
The La mommies really represented. Yeah,
it was fun.
Ranch Dotcom and buy some tickets
to see those big mushy purples.
He really enunciates.
Your Dad's got a broadcaster's voice.
I was in ranch.com it was big
mushy purples. Yeah, he
really says it well. Yeah,
you're very handsome. I love
you. Thank you. I love you too.
I'd like to be with you. I want to
be with you. Don't give me gonorrhea.
Don't fund my friends,
Dude.
She had bad dreams about me and
then hate me a little bit. The next
I've had. Yes, but not, it
was never carried in cause
I've woken up and be like, oh,
that was a dream. Yeah, but it's
unconscious. It's just I can't help it.
Jean Jean, I had jeans, my new favorite.
Unless you make some new friends you have
nothing to worry about because no one
is going to be,
come on. No, we don't like my
friends cause they're not blondes.
No one's going to the dog pound.
They're not dogs, they're just Burnett.
They're all grumpy brunettes.
We're just having to be,
the best question I get asked all the
time is what makes monads pizzas so
different and it's not really that easy
of a question to answer without going
into a little bit of detail,
please don't go behind the scenes and
take a look at what we do with our cheese.
What we do with our Dell, what we do with
our tomatoes can make this pizza union.
Our cheese is an piece of the
puzzle.
It's the middle child bridging the gap
between the crust and the toxic glue that
holds it all together.
It's, it's delicious.
It is a beautiful thing to watch a master
cheesemaker preside over at new master
ways.
Just watching every step in a way to
make sure it's perfect and they have made
us great.
When we talk about Mozzarella cheese.
Oh God. We're talking about a
product that it needs to be creamy.
Duh. Yeah. Yeah. What's the fucking
say? Well, it's like, I don't know.
Good. His cheese is really fucking,
I do. I do want to try it now. Right?
Don't you think this guy is probably,
it's probably a pretty good, right? What?
Do we know the, is this la? No, no.
It's creamy. Buttery. Oh,
you get a little teary,
Rudy. Well, no, no. Naughty.
Oh, stop it. Stop it. Really,
really good.
You're annoying.
Really
stop it. Yeah, it's Monatiz. That's gross.
That's really gross.
It was super boring and it's boring.
And he's a boner is an exciting topic
that he made. Boring. How's that possible?
You can make pizza and we look
forward. My favorite one of these, um,
was the one we did at the live
show where she's like dry ponds.
Now you may have heard of dry ponds,
right?
But the dry ponds in this dry pond
is a dry pond. Yeah. Oh my God.
[inaudible] pond is where there
used to be water. It's also,
it was like really obvious, but you know,
when there's water, but then there isn't,
now it's a dry pond. Yeah, no, I
got it. Yeah, it was so boring.
And dry pounds can be either dry or ponds,
but they're not both dry ponds.
They're like, yeah, what are you talking
about? So when the water goes away,
now it's a dry pond. You're
like, Yep, that's how you do it.
Teaching us about drive. How can we talk
about sink holes for a minute? Yeah.
I don't understand what's happening with
the sinkhole. Why don't you understand?
Well, we had a huge storms
and la this last weekend.
And then in studio city they said there
was a sinkhole and that just means that
what the earth just collapses and
sucks in everything around it.
Particular area. I mean, the
answer is simply yes. Uh,
there was a sinkhole that it opened
on the street level and below it was,
you know, the, uh, what's it
called? Like the, the water,
what is it that runs through
underneath the tunnel? The,
uh, you know, I forget what
it's called anyways. Yeah.
It was like sewage lines basically
like an open flooded. So the water, uh,
it was raining so much, right. That, um,
I guess that area was just
susceptible to it swallowed two cars.
Did you see that? That's what I'm
saying. So, okay. So basically it gets,
sometimes there's sinkholes in that area.
It was above like a
functioning, um, you know,
sewage system line. Okay. So then that
breaks down and they think it sucks in,
okay. There are sinkholes
that happened just, you know,
terrain opens up. That's what
the fuck I'm talking about. Yeah.
Like when we used to live by the beach,
I would walk to the ocean. It was one,
one time on the beach. Yeah. Dude. Like
just out of nowhere, the sand collapses.
And you're like, how does that even,
how, why? And how does that even happen?
This shit is,
is uh,
no crazy. Crazier than a
motherfucker, man. Ooh,
this is ray. We need, um,
we need a boring video to explain
sinkholes to us. Look one up.
Let's see how you is one.
Oh,
what's your tongue of bad?
Crazy.
Let's see. Let's go. Um,
this same as this one seems to vary.
Our scientists have discovered evidence
in rock layers to date or history on a
geological timescale at
about 4.6 billion years old.
These scientists borings have internal
and external energies already tapped out
the various land structures of these
energies or for shorter version
constructive from this
map of the United States,
sinkholes occur in different regions
all across the USA and beyond.
Worldwide,
Huh?
Okay. Did you see that one called how
scary sinkholes are freaking thank you.
And better at any time. Yeah. I
don't understanding our intro.
This guy's gonna drag it down.
Yeah, we're going to learn words.
I can understand here for d news,
people and sink holes are now in
my list of things I fear most.
Right under trapped by a wildfire
and above giant spider attacks.
Prison sinkholes. This reason a man
was asleep in bed in his Florida home.
It's totally the earth gave way
under his house. It was a sinkhole.
He screamed for his brother
who rushed in to save him.
But even with those few seconds,
it was too long. Kind of help.
I know the best way to get over it.
A fear of something is to get to know it.
So here goes.
All right.
Sinkholes happen when the bedrock of the
earth is slowly worn away by erosion.
It's particularly common in places that
are built mostly on limestone because
it's so susceptible to that erosion
under the topsoil is a layer called the
overburden. Then under that is
bedrock, which sounds tough and solid,
but it's actually filled with cracks
and crevices. Water's constantly,
legally the water, the water,
water eats away at the rock.
The fucking water gums in,
Huh?
Snotty. Even you saying like
it wasn't so much water,
they wouldn't, yeah. Laughs
we got to deport the water.
It's raining too much, man. We gotta
get rid of all the water rounded up.
Oddly enough, everyone's always
complaining about a drought here. Yeah.
What the surface is a thin crust of soil
until the person walks over at course,
cause it all collapses.
Sinkholes.
In 2010 Guatemala City was
hit by Hurricane Agatha,
and after being slammed
with 45 mile an hour winds,
the rain finally proved too much
and caused this gaping hole. Oh,
an entire factory. The thing is, you
feed across and like a hundred feet deep.
It looks Photoshop. It most
definitely. Whoa, dude. Scary.
Luckily no one was injured.
Guatemala City is built on ancient
volcanic ash and pumice just Kinda like
gravel. And when it erodes, this happens.
That's not, and it could happen anytime.
Anytime a hard rain comes or whatever.
There's nothing they can do. Singles,
sinkholes aren't always
caused by rain or nature.
Sometimes humans screw things up.
We're pretty good at that.
Broken sewer pipes flooded. Mozzies are
underground records been known to come?
Is it?
You know what's crazy too is like,
there's always this illusion that
everything's fine. Don't worry about,
we're in constant chaos any
moment. You know, it's, it's,
it's a weird way about how the earth,
the world,
even in modern times, is susceptible
to its origins. In other words,
the natural state. I don't have
many buildings with Nia. You know,
big biotron signs, you go
like, well now it's modern,
but like the earth can still open
up and swallow you. Right Bro.
I was fucking divas. Fuck.
And you're right. Yeah. Cause
we can build technology.
We can say that we have control.
We have no control over her mother nature.
She can fucking zero do a tornado.
A Tornado.
Fucking earthquake. Dude, forget it.
Good luck with your fancy freeways and
your buildings. When that shit happens,
earth opens up. That's what's up. Go Walk.
Yeah,
yeah,
no shit.
I remember it in the big earthquake
in 1994 when that happened here in la,
freeways just collapsed on top
of freeways. And guess what?
If you're fucking under it, like
you're just dead, you're dead.
You know the one thing about that is,
it's much scarier is that their sudden
I lived through a bunch of hurricanes.
I hate that Florida. That's
terrifying piece. You have warnings.
You know the warnings.
That changes a lot because they're like
a hurricane is coming and then you're
just fucking dumb if you're around for it.
But why do people stay?
Because there are people that
I've learned over time. It's a,
it's a mixture of dumb people,
poor people.
Because poor people
really think about like,
I don't have the means to
travel or stay somewhere.
I never thought about that for
a long time, but it is true.
But then there are dummies like there
are one zero like I don't give a fuck.
You know what? I didn't get killed
last time. I sure shit like that.
And then they stick around and
die like don't Dan race. Yeah.
They risk it and then they just
get screwed. I wish we could,
I mean they've tried forever.
They've been trying forever to
develop an earthquake system.
Like they could give us warning at least
like a few minutes because that would
help tremendously.
But you're, you're just fucking
screwed dude. It's fucking,
yeah, it's a nightmare.
That's why I don't like doing much.
I feel like the less I do the safe right,
I am better you can do is like, just
stay home all the time. All the time.
Our House is super safe. We're safe
in here. I feel like. Think so.
Unless there's a sinkhole beneath us.
So I think about that every night.
Put that in your dreams.
Put me with one of your friends having
sex in a sinkhole and your dreams real
scared.
The good news is you have life insurance.
Please make some better looking
friends paid. They're all good looking.
They're just brunettes. Blondes.
You got a bunch of fucking
what about
not true of everyone about that?
And I'm like,
all your friends are here by your dog
pound and your fucking dog friends.
Maybe your friends are Bowser's.
I got g Q squad is, oh, bullshit.
The bt Gq.
The Big Tom is quarters
there elects the Hobo squad.
That's your fucking squad.
That's what you're into. You
liked. You liked that Hobo.
I am actually more to do it for you. How
both score Hobo looking guy. I'm like,
my wife would like you to
come over, do it for you, man.
Just like stupid.
Just like the gate.
I was like, would you ever
one date your mom? Yes.
I hope those people fall into singles. A
dumb dumbs. You want to see a dad boner,
a lightning strike?
I always,
yes,
I know.
Excited Dad is my favorite thing.
A blue band.
Can you put a compilation together of
all excited dad footage that we've had so
many excited dad master
compilation of this shit.
Is he a professional professional?
It looks like he's in a broadcasting
kind of jacket and he's outside.
It's snowing like crazy.
I mean there's,
I don't know how much snow was on the
ground and there's lightening and that's
his reaction every time he sees light.
Yes.
Why is he so stoked about it? It seems
like he's at the television Guy, right?
There's somebody behind them and not
like a home video isn't a home video I've
really picked up there.
You gotta be kidding.
How can this guy,
how does
have a job looks terrible out there. I
would go inside. Yeah, it's horrible.
You can have your $500 million Jackpot
and powerball or whatever the heck it was.
But I'll take this baby for four
lightening strikes for episodes of thunder
snow.
Okay. Thunder snow. Huh? That's
his shots. His Jam under snow.
Most people watch lightening strike.
He would rather not have a half a billion
dollars. He just said, then see like
you can have your jackpot. I just saw
lightning strike four times. Yeah.
I don't feel like it's that exciting.
I feel like I've seen,
hopefully not that exciting
and I'm excited for him. Yeah.
But I'm not that excited neither.
I would stab him in front of his children
to get $500 million. So what I, yeah,
he's crazy.
I mean, this is just a total change. Not
only was it an hour was shot another one.
What's up? Oh my goodness.
That's number six.
You've gotta be kidding me. I
tell you, this is Chicago books,
Jealousy, Chicago all over again.
We're just sitting in the middle of it,
just like all over. So he's in. Wow. Wow.
I've never seen someone get
this excited about lightning.
It's really exciting for him. There's
nothing more exciting on earth and that,
is there anything you could get this
stoked about? I mean, I don't, you know,
it's like he has one passion and
it's fucking lighten this jam. Yeah.
You know what I'd be excited about?
Oh Dude. That's number
six. I like the baby.
I'd like to see the Aurora borealis.
Yeah, but there's no Alaska be cool.
You ever react like, I mean, I've seen
you go about that. I'm trying to think.
I get excited about the dads.
Yeah. You guys side by seeing them.
I don't know if there's anything that
you feel that passionate about it like
that.
Like that.
Like that time I met Kim deal
from the pixies was pretty amazed.
I was really excited about that.
You're fun to surprise cause you
get excited on surprises. Yeah.
Time I flew your friend out.
That was the best day on her side.
That was the most exciting time.
Yeah. That was super fun. Yeah. Yeah.
That was a good surprise. Yeah. That
was so clever. She's cute by the way.
She's totally cute. I no kidding
me. She doesn't live here.
You know they can't banger.
Exactly. Fly around, but exactly.
I'm talking about you're accessible.
Dog Pound. Oh, you're so stupid.
Which one of your friends
is a winner there?
Which one of your friends is
a big catch? Let me see. Huh?
They're all fucking your friends.
Yeah.
Well shot another one.
Wow.
Fucking heard. Yeah, he's a super
nerd. What can, I'm not, I mean,
Brussels Griffon I'm so our son,
but even like look at Ellis do that
would make me that. Yeah. Know,
like the boy makes us pretty excited.
Yeah. Yeah. With good reason.
Yeah. But no, I don't, I don't see us. I
don't know. I definitely don't get that.
You always make fun of me for not
excited. You have no feelings. Oh,
that's not true.
That I have no feelings.
You don't have excitement or I assume
you get excited watching games now.
There was, you know what you get
excited about. Yeah. Football, um,
killers like serial killer murder shows.
I don't get excited about them.
You never get, I mean, it's literally
like, Tom, I'm pregnant. And you're like,
oh yeah, no, that's also a lie.
You're a fucking liar. You exaggerate.
You weren't as excited as fake news,
fake news.
You weren't as excited as I thought
you'd be when I announced like pregnancy.
You were like, well, that's
great. Yeah, great. Yeah,
I'm going to barbecue.
And then you barbecued,
you went outside and you barbecued.
That's not true. I didn't go.
That's great news. I'm going
to barbecue. That's not neat.
I didn't say you didn't get super
stoked and then you're like, all right,
and then you just start a
barbecuing. I remember. Oh
full of shit. What do you get?
You don't get excited.
No,
you like rappers and stuff like you
get stuck when you meet rappers.
Not like that, but yeah,
I got excited. Come on.
I got excited when we were having a baby
toy. Please back. Like I wasn't excited.
Speaking of babies in a baby doing this.
Let's see how it is.
Yup.
Tanya. Tanya said, yeah, this
is Tanya. Okay, excellent work,
Tanya.
Getting them young.
It's a cute kid. Your kid. Cute
little glass and kid. Totally.
Um,
oh.
So apparently this is
you God doing standup.
I don't want to hear it. I don't
want to see it. Whatever it is.
It's stupid having vocal
fry. Oh, shut the front door.
Let's see what it says here.
Stop it.
Please submit evidence of Christina's
vocal snippets of her old standards.
Okay. You're so shitty. I won't, I won't
put it up, but let's do here for a sec.
Wait a sec. Let's see if you have vocal
fry, please don't play. It went like this.
Okay, fine. Great. There's my vocal
fi. So you had it. There was probably,
I was probably going low in
the register. Oh, that's true.
All right,
that's on a punchline.
I have the video. Would you like
to see the new? No, I don't.
I don't want to see the video
you have. Um, you have stand up.
Especially,
I don't want to slow,
painful the kind of person
that enjoys everything I do.
I love your bag. 10 years
old, Babe. Love your bed.
That's when we lived in the
Rampart division. I had banks.
What's took a quick, no,
I don't want to watch my old jokes.
Let's please don't go quick.
You're an asshole and I'm going
to get you back if you do it.
We're watching your first year. I'm going
to find that you got all your standup.
By the way, if every fucking thing you've
ever done on CD, you'd VHS. Can we,
can we do this though? No. Let me
finish my sentence. Whatever it is. No.
Can we pull it up and pause it just so
I can look at you so I can look at your
hair? You're lying because I know
we'll do, I've known him for 12 years,
so it's muted me in it.
The volume on the volume.
I just want to look at your hair.
Oh my God. It's so embarrassing.
This was a badge. Ah, I had good teeth
though. And look at those gold earrings.
What phase is like going through?
God that's so old.
That hair like a skinny. I was,
I was wearing a name nameplate.
My mom gave me from Brooklyn. Oh
yeah. I was wearing big goals.
Who've earrings, gas. Going through
like a, some kind of, I was wearing um,
rockoware a lot that year for some reason.
I don't know what,
what kind of phases was man. Yeah,
I look good though. You look great.
Skinny Tan. This is when we first
started dating. Did you look great?
It's like 10 years ago, bu
wait more. This is when I was,
when we first started dating,
I went to Korea this year.
To do stand up. Uh, that's,
yeah,
you went to Korea after we,
I mean this is right when I was
working as a writer. Still you look,
I was working at a bakery [inaudible]
the name of the company that was working
as a writer. I've got my spank
bank ready to go. Great. Nice.
Banks are not a good look
for me. I thought they were
great. I loved those banks.
Are you fucking serious? No. Serious. Yes.
I like it. They're really uncomfortable.
I don't care about that. I care that it
looks really, it looks so comfortable.
It's uncomfortable because they,
they grow past your eyebrows really
fast and then you have to constantly get
them trimmed.
It's like the never ending quest to
keep your banks the right length.
And if they get too long
then they're in your eyes.
It's sucks you got hair
in your face all the time.
With banks from, was I
thinking a name plate? Oh,
that was the time sex in
the city who was begging.
Everyone was wearing when cause Sarah
Jessica Parker had one situation that is
so old. My tits were great. You
know why they weren't that big?
They were cs cause I was skinnier. I was
about 10 pounds lighter than I am now.
And My tits were manageable.
Maybe Ds One D. Yeah.
Tan. No wrinkles yet. Oh Man.
Now's a good time. Look how cute. I was
back to confident too for that long ago.
You're supercar thank,
I could tell were not even leading
myself until like the way that your pool,
that's a Rocka wear jacket.
Fucking eye contact.
This was a disaster,
this comedy time.
So these people would tape your sets
and everyone's signed away their their
rights 10 years ago and if you
bombed that night, they didn't care.
So, and then you'd ask them, can you take
that fucking down? They're like, nope.
You signed the paperwork and they fucked
over so many comics who ate shit on
Carlton Stream it now. So they get
paid on that. Such fucking turds.
I would never do that again.
Think we didn't know it was like the
beginning of the Internet when people were
putting Stanhope up. Yeah,
we didn't know. Yeah,
it's so bad.
Scumbags.
Total scumbags gum bag.
Well,
I'm glad I had vocal fry on
their fucking thing. Comedy time.
Douche bags. Um, thanks guys.
Thanks for scouring the
Internet and finding shit 20
years ago and road rules or
10 years ago.
This here is a a,
it looks like this lady seems to have
accidentally taken the wrong drink at
Starbucks. In other
words, they put something,
I think she took the wrong one
and she's fucking loses her mind.
Oh yeah.
[inaudible] they're like
fucking white people.
She's having a panic attack. White people
are the worst. That's another touch.
Assholes to great title for an uh,
a special to white people are
the worst. Writing it down. Yeah.
It's a really good title.
You got it.
[inaudible]
Holy Shit. She's mentally ill. So
do you understand? I understand.
I think it would happen now.
She said,
you said that the next thing
we're going to be mine. So,
and then there's a second round,
the third round.
So they keep saying like your
thanks coming your drink. She's
laughing. Like look at his psycho.
Worried about a fucking drink.
Starbucks
personal [inaudible]
and that Starbucks employee you've got
to give credit was like really patient,
really understanding great company.
Yeah.
Because part of you wants to go like,
Hey,
are you fucking serious right now that
you're freaking out that I said your
drink was next and it's not.
You see these cups,
yours is one of these chill the fuck out.
Ain't no,
it's called and she just takes a,
she's just take one of those hundred
and 60 degree cups and just knowing that
Lady's face that was your drink. The
Fuck Outta here with that shit. Yeah.
Well she's got other problems as you
can tell by the outfit and you like this
type of behavior is tolerable and
about seven countries in the world and
everywhere else.
Oh,
somebody just sticks a straw in your
neck just like drink out of that bitch.
Well yeah.
Could you imagine doing this and like
in Guatemala where the sinkhole have,
they'd be like, what? Why
are you, you're retarded.
Throw you on the street there yet
addressed you. Yeah. Crazy person.
Someone would beat you and
no one would stop it. No.
And then when the police came,
so it be like that bitch was
going crazy about her shrink.
So I kicked her and they'd
be like, okay, good. Yeah,
cause I don't even
think in eastern Europe,
this shit would never held in Hungary
or Budapest if you didn't get your drink
right. They'd be like, fuck you,
get outta here. Oh, okay. Yeah.
There's no such thing as
the customer being right in
other countries, by the way,
that is what the problem is,
is that the customer is always
right and that is a lousy mantra.
So stupid monkey.
They're not always right dude.
And if you've worked in customer service,
you fucking know that there's a lot of
crazy people out there too. Crazy. Really?
That's what's going on here.
Customers not right.
She's definitely crazy.
Then
now she's gonna fuck an email list this
week I saw that I was on your podcast
and I was very excited
and we look bad.
[inaudible]
can I tell you something like,
honestly,
deep down when that happens to me,
I panicked a little too.
Once my drink coming, like when
we see other people getting there.
Before you and you know you
were here before though.
It's definitely something you recognized
and a feeling, but reacting like that.
So you don't, I don't let it out, but
I have it. I do have it, nick about it.
And you're like, but that's what you do
is your eyes are like, and then you go,
art is mine.
Is there one there for Christina?
And then they go, what is yours? You're
like, it's, it's, I think it's that cup.
Oh yeah, we'll be there in a minute. Okay.
You don't do that because that's too far.
But that was a child temper
tantrum. You know, children react.
That's how I see.
Or I feel that way 100%.
Right. But then as an adult you go, oh,
that's not appropriate. Yeah, you can't,
you can't react that dead face.
It's so great. You thought that was yours
and now you're fucking flipping out.
Crazy white lady.
That is crazy white lady
named crazy white lady.
I like crazy white lady. That's
pretty funny actually. Um, oh,
I guess I would play a crazy
white ladies good before we leave,
but I need to have a joke
about it. Yeah, I know.
You can't just have you fill your
mind with different idea, you know,
and then figuring out crazy white lady.
White people are the worst.
Why did people are terrible? They
really are. The reason everything sucks.
It's so true.
We,
we tried to culturally a
dominate everybody else.
We think we're the best. Yeah,
we, yeah, we're just douche bags.
We've ruined the world.
Absolutely. Hey Mommy,
how's it going? Good.
Just glass and I mean I'm saying I just
get a medium iced coffee as with toasted
almond coconut. Could you
just flew up on that? Listen,
some know and I'm going to be that like
burnt and get whipped cream on top and
could you just fill it up and
[inaudible] awesome. Sure. Thank you.
Wow. That was Sammy, Sammy Shit. That was,
that sounded scripted. Yeah, it was
great. She got so many in there. So many.
She closed it on,
fill it up and seal it shut.
Can you fluid bond that amazed and
he liked the timing was perfect.
Oh, he's like, Yup. Yup. No
problem. Yup. You got it.
That was perfect. Thank you Sammy. Wow.
Um,
Jerry here,
I see you're a Jack Munchie meal and
I was wondering if that comes high and
tight or if only in the medium size.
Hi.
I said I'll was glassing
in my hammock and uh,
my senior Jack My hammock and I was
wondering if that comes high and tight or
Justin. Um, medium. Just one size. Okay.
I'll take that one size.
Hi.
We're trying to send to me.
Um, I'll take the, uh, chicken
and 10 days double pump classic.
Oh yeah, yeah, that'll be it.
And what?
Um, I'm the water champ. All
of the interim water champs.
All Taiko a water and
I'll take a Powerade.
I bought a water and a power and the side.
Oh,
can you do the water in a cup?
Thank you.
Uh,
what flavors do you have?
Jeans?
Uh, definitely do cherry. All
right. That'll be amazing.
Um, I don't want to be fat like
Burt's, so yeah, that'd be it.
That's Jerry?
Yeah.
Zach. Okay. Haley handler.
Can I four for four deal?
Um, it's always junior bacon
cheeseburger. Oh, it's Friday here.
That and coke.
High and tight.
Uh, yes, please. Okay.
Um, some rash. Okay.
Yeah, it's going to do it.
Five 9,600 went down. Thank you.
All right, thanks. Jane's love you.
The Hay. Hitler Hitler's are
just w he did one of those.
Sometimes people will be like,
hey, look like that. It's real.
Kind of like kind of hide it. Yeah, he
did a clear one, you know? Yeah. Okay.
Haley handler.
Can I get hang up?
So that's like a on that super cut.
That guy goes, thank you Hitler.
It gets me every time I, this doesn't,
it never gets old for me. I know.
I could watch these all day.
Somebody did one of these.
Hey Mommy, can I stay a
Bristol stool chart number two,
sausage shape below B.
Yeah.
Number two. Yeah. All
right. Thanks. Jeans.
Hey, can I ask you something?
Would you ever date your mom?
You date your mom? I mean,
it's just like the gays.
It's just like, it's just like some
crazy people out there for that.
Yeah. You mean as well? They
didn't know. They were like,
they were in love with
someone like, no, no,
I'm talking about Dave,
your mother, you can't,
so they said no, I would
not date him. I'm like,
don't, no, I wouldn't answer.
Then I would say no. You say no.
Yeah. Okay. All bars. All right.
I'll mark you down as a note.
I mean people worth to you
that nurtured you in her womb.
Once you come out of that, there should be
no going back. Yeah. You don't go. Yeah,
I stayed the same. I do. I'm a
crazy browns.
Oh Wow. She threw in a thanks.
Hitler, Rachel and Shawn.
Wow. You ran into what? What people
are not used to running into,
which is somebody engaging a person. Yeah.
It's set up somewhere being like, no,
yeah, no, I wouldn't. Whatever. He was
like, wait, what? It was like, yeah,
really thoughtful, articulate guy who
was like, what are you saying? Yeah.
What are you saying? What? How was
it like the gays? Yeah, exactly.
That guy didn't throw that away.
He was like,
that is a dumb thing that
you could possibly say
because it is. It is. It
is. It is the decoy. Yeah.
I mean that's why that's the dumb, it's
the dumbest comparison. So that guy goes,
how is that?
Which is exactly what you should think
when somebody says it's like the gates,
but I love how she really plays it off
and she was like, it's just, it is wrong.
It's what some people say. Like he
really was like, oh, it's old herself.
Like asking the question. In other
words. Yeah. She made it seem like it's,
it's a worthwhile, but she's like, we're,
they're saying there. It's a debate.
It's a debate.
I'm going to mark you down as a no,
she's taking a survey.
Genius level. Genius.
Sammy.
That's her name. Sammy and
Sean, I think it said, I don't
know. Genius. Genius level.
No, Rachel, sorry. Rachel.
Rachel and Sean genius.
Really good stuff.
And then this kind of taking a survey.
Could I please get a number two in the
mouth? Throw hammock. Just the sandwich.
A number. Sure, sure.
One cheese and ketchup only seubert
sized super size with a throat Cilla to
drink. We don't have coke. Zero
in the Dragon. Oh, that's fine.
You say about the fries.
A supersized please.
Regular time.
Seubert sized or larger size and
large network. Oh yeah. Yep. Okay.
Anything else? Oh my God, Eh, uh,
five piece nugget. Oh, sorry.
I'm not glass and I can't see which one.
Uh,
just a six
births.
Going to want lots of ranch.
Please block out the ranch. Yeah.
Alright. Anything else?
Nope, that'll do. All right.
And did you want anything special on the
double a? No. Thanks. Okay. All right.
Let me 1547 at the first one.
No thanks Warren.
Unreal. Super Right. Super.
And then stuck with it. Yeah.
Didn't go with a large, no. Super
Amazed. She's like, I think largest.
And then he said the, uh, oh shit. What
was the other one? He died that was good.
Throughout Zillow throws. Zella yeah,
that was great. She goes, coke zero.
We don't have that. God. That's uh,
this is, uh, I'm taking a shit homie
by Ramsay McQueen as our closing song.
Wow. Okay. It was a lot of fun
today. Thanks guys. Thanks Jean.
We we enjoyed you as always. Thanks
for, uh, for listening and, uh,
we'll see you next week. It's fluid
bond soon. Uh, your mom's house,
podcast.com thousand ranch
Dotcom Thompson Jr com.
We'll see you next time.
Thanks mommies.
This dude,
this kid crawls under a
stall in the bathroom,
but I'm thinking that look in his
eye is a revealing these tests.
Either he's touched or he's on drugs,
he's tweaking ensemble and he doesn't
know what the fuck he's doing.
You didn't never crawl under us.
What are you good
boy?
Can't believe how much this kid kept
it together. That's taken a shift.
I think 98% of the population would
not be able to view it this way.
I know I would. I'd be
like, Dude, I'm shitting
rob or shooting the
shit. Dude, I'm shitting
shitting your terms. Ron. Ron,
what are you doing? Hey, wake up.
Wake up thinking
about
blowing up.
Shit.
It's Kinda,
it's Kinda
scary because at the end,
the guy that's Charles
really close to the team
that way
and had abrupt stops.